Here in the kitchen.
I'm with my culinary partner in crime and my dearest friend,
Chef Pilar Valdes.
(audience clapping)
And when I say culinary partner in crime,
this is our new, turns out it's a New York Times bestseller.
(audience clapping)
Thank gosh that our cookbook, Rebel Homemaker,
we have a recipe in here that is
very near and dear to my heart.
This is the squash gratin with a cashew cream.
And one of the things that I love most about this, Pilar, is
because I think that those beautiful, hardy, creamy,
you know, fulfilling sides are such a big part
of holiday dinner planning
and this is such a healthy approach.
There's so many recipes in here that we swap out
little different ingredients,
so that you're really getting something delicious,
but it's really healthy.
And we kind of sneak it in there
and you never know the difference.
So from this page, we are gonna show you how you can make
this, too, for you Christmas dinner
or really any time of the year.
So let's get cookin'.
Squash gratin, here we go.
So first step, Drew, is we're gonna make the cashew cream.
So it's basically vegan
and all you have to do is soak the raw cashews.
How long do you soak them for, Pilar?
So if you do hot water, soak them in hot water,
you can actually get away with just one hour.
But you can also just stick them in the fridge overnight
and it's totally fine.
So these are the soaked cashews,
and we're gonna pour in a little bit of water.
One cup of water.
And then some Dijon, because this dish, it has the cream,
it has almond milk, it has these beautiful
caramelized onions.
So it tends to go, it can go a little sweet,
so the Dijon is gonna cut through that really nicely.
Also, if you're like a cooking show fanatic like I am,
here's some apple cider vinegar.
You can always hear judges talking about
I need a little bit of that acid.
So this is a perfect balancer for that
And then you put it in the miso next.
And the miso is just gonna sort of round it out,
give that umami.
And salt.
It's really, really, it just brings the dish
to a whole other level.
All right, so we're gonna blend that up.
Here we go.
In my blender.
(Pilar heralding)
(blender whirring)
All right, that feels really good.
Now I got it.
So as we were doing that.
(audience clapping)
And this is our beautiful blender.
And I will tell you, it rivals the best of the best,
I'm so proud of it
'cause that blender has really gotta function for you.
(audience clapping)
Okay, so I'm gonna swap out my cashew cream here.
Absolutely.
So we've got some red onions sauteing
and they have some sage
and some thyme, and I like to add a lot of black pepper.
And then basically what you're gonna do is put
in a little bit of chopped thyme,
a little bit of nutmeg,
and you can actually try it with cinnamon.
Cinnamon and nutmeg, those warm spices are really great
with the squashes, which is what we're using today.
So you're gonna saute that until it gets nice, caramelized,
and all those flavors start to sing and blend.
But not brown.
Definitely not definitely not burnt.
You want them to get like soft and caramel-y.
And then all you have to do is just turn off the heat
and actually whisk in or stir in your almond milk.
And I just whisked in my cashew cream, as well,
which is what we just pureed earlier.
And so these are, if you've not seen them before,
these are what the delicata squash looks like.
And you literally just slice 'em up into rings
and they make a beautiful side dish
in almost any preparation.
And are so easy.
And you don't have to peel them.
So what I'm gonna do actually is gonna start building
the dish.
So you have your sauce all ready to go
and I'm gonna use this guy, I think.
And what you're gonna do is basically pour in
a little bit of that sauce into the bottom of your dish.
And then you're gonna take these slices of delicata.
You're basically gonna shingle them, kind of like a roof,
you know?
A little bit overlapping in this beautiful manner.
So I'm gonna continue layering, but actually, Drew,
you have a almost-finished casserole over there.
If you wanna do the last layers
and then we can just pop that in the oven.
I do.
And it's gonna be good to go.
So you want to finish with the cream sauce on top.
Yep, and get it kind of into those edges
'cause what we're gonna do, Drew, is basically bake it
until the squash is fully cooked and fully tender,
but not mushy.
So that's gonna be about 40 minutes.
So we're gonna pop that in the oven
at 400 degrees for about 40 minutes.
400 at 40 minutes.
Until the squash is tender.
And I'm gonna grab this guy.
Ooh, he's far. (laughing)
Ooh.
Oh that's beautiful.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.
Also, one thing that for me always changes
the face of a dish and it's what restaurants do,
and that's what separates a home cook
from a professional chef.
It's as simple as a garnish.
Crispy sage.
So all you do is basically take like a tablespoon
of olive oil, drop the sage leaf in and it's gonna
sort of sputter and frizzle for like 30 seconds.
Pull it out, paper towel, salt it,
and you use that as your garnish and it gives
this wonderful aroma, a nice little crisp texture,
and there you have it.
I'm so proud of this dish.
It's one of the many recipes in our cookbook
that we're so excited to have developed and share with you.
(audience clapping)
I'm digging in.
Oh, it's just so beautiful.
it's so good.
You know, I just want to eat right out of the bowl, Pilar.
Go for it, go for it.
It's hard for me to be proper in times like this
because my true self just wants to, mm, motor boat
right there inside the bowl.
I love you.
Love you.
Happy holidays.
(audience clapping)
Why is it that when food is so good,
it just makes me mad?
(Pilar laughing)
When food is so good, it just makes me straight up mad
and I guess that's why we called it Rebel Homemaker
because we all wanna be not perfect.
I think that's the name of the game right now.
Let's not pretend, let's not encourage that in each other,
let's just be the unique individuals
that each one of us are.
And to want you to be a homemaker is to make a space
that gives you that mental wellness,
something that you know going out and working so hard for,
there is the payoff.
And if you want to bring people into that home
and be an entertainer and include them in that privilege,
what a wonderful way to live.
So let's all be rebel homemakers.
(audience clapping)
Cheers!
(uplifting music)